[Music]
welcome to another episode of vme end to
end a show where you have someone that's
a little skeptical of ems and someone
that's a little more enthusiastic about
them on the show to hash out all things
vm brian thanks so much for being here
today i've got a tricky one for you okay
uh let's go
yeah yeah i want to know about uh
cutting edge technology like really
pushing cloud compute machines to the
limit i think this is gonna be one
that's gonna trip us up
i have the perfect person for us to
bring in and talk to you about this i
would like to introduce
emma welcome emma hi
thank you for having me today
yes so happy to be able to talk with you
uh if i'm not mistaken you made an
amazing world record-breaking uh pie
calculator using google cloud and
compute yes yes it was in 2019 so it's a
little bit old but it was a world record
yes can we get an overview of that
project a little bit uh what was it sure
so
there are competitions around pi
the number begins with 3.14 and people
can try to calculate as many digits as
possible and the world record we did was
three no 31.4 trillion digits
on google cloud using 25 machines
spending 121 days and 100 terabytes of
storage
and we did that but this scale is why i
wanted to invite emma in because um
you know there's not a lot of people
that have run
you know machines full on
for you know four months straight um and
i think more interestingly kind of
worked through
where the bottlenecks are in a system
when you try to do that like where were
the bottlenecks in this process sure so
the bottleneck was the storage
so in order to calculate pi you need a
lot of stretch 107 terabytes but the the
amount you
you read and write is enormous uh we
wrote about nine petabytes sorry eight
petabytes and read
nine petabytes a petabyte is thousand
terabytes so it's approximately
17 000 terabytes of data you need to
process
and the stretch
io was the biggest bottleneck this is
one this is mind breaking to me because
i would not expect cloud compute to be
able to handle that like that was my
assumption coming into this uh was this
one of the first projects of its type to
do this or is this like commonplace in
the cloud
i think it's getting more and more
common these days a lot of people just
run
high performance computing this type of
massive workload on cloud
so then my question would be
um what are some of the advantages of
doing this in the cloud because if i if
i did this on prem i kind of understand
what that looks like a little bit i'd
buy a lot of my machines up front
uh i would try and work through it from
there how does it look like for the
cloud so i think the coolest part of
using cloud is you don't need to
choose which machine or which
architecture to use up front so for
example if you are buying a physical
machine you actually need to decide how
many cores you're getting
how much storage you're you're
assigning to that machine et cetera et
cetera but with cloud you can always try
and um test different parameters for
example
do i need a 100 gigabytes memory or 200
gigabytes or do i need 64 cores 128
cores you can try and test these
parameters
in the real
environment
so you basically do small versions of it
and kind of see how much work you get
for a certain amount of time and money
and like see how that turns out
wow
this is really cool um
something i'm really curious about is
okay you said this was in 2019 and it's
you know not the new record now or
whatever but what would be different if
you were coding the same thing say
you're trying to do 32 trillion digits
of pi again
how um
what like what would change if you took
that same code base now and just i don't
know could you update it for some of the
compute technology now or what yeah so
with cloud you can just change the
parameters and and use the latest cpus
and machines we have today
for example we have the latest
intel and md processors we have more
memory for machine for example the
biggest machine we have is
11 terabytes of memory and we have
newer
persistent disk types that achieves
lower cost and higher throughput and we
have increased the network bandwidth
from 16 gigabits per second to 100
gigabits per second so
by using all of these um i think we can
probably finish the calculation in a
quarter of the time we did in 2019.
there's a kind of saying you know time
is money and at some level that's just
even more true in cloud right so if you
make something faster it costs less to
run so that's a big deal can we actually
talk about that a little bit uh what was
like say the cost of this in 2019 and
then you said it's you know
four times faster what would the cost of
it look like now just you know estimates
sure so
um if you don't work for google you
probably pay a lot for this project and
it was about three hundred thousand
dollars to calculate pi
if you
pay
the money as an extra external customer
and
um you get
uh
half the of the storage
for half the price today uh achieve the
same boundary so that cut that goes
about 30 because the biggest cost was
the storage and we have a fast processor
we we can use the intel
isolate xeon processors and
we have increased network bandwidth so
in combine
it took about four months to finish the
calculation i think we can do something
between a month
probably
40 50 days so
you pay less
part time like you pay less per hour and
you finish the calculation faster so by
combining all of these factors i think
um it's safe to say we pay much much
less today
that's awesome so like same
same project over time gets cheaper and
cheaper um that seemed like a win
but it seemed like you also did a lot of
you know like there's a lot of
variations for how things could be done
you talked about like um you know
running experiments basically
um
if people wanted to run their own
experiments on their own software how
would you recommend they they approach
that sure
um so there are tons of configurations
and variables in cloud and probably with
your software you want to run in cloud
and
of course you can automate some of the
um
aspects for your software and there is a
tool to automate that default cloud as
well it's called infrastructure as a
code and we use um tools like terraform
and plumi and to
actually write down all the
configuration parameters as a script and
run it
and the coolest part is you can
automate
the
deployment and provisioning process so
for example if you want to test with
different cpu cores like 2 4 8
16 32
64
then you just need to write a for loop
and run the script again again and
invoke the software
and run the test for all these
combinations and that's what you can do
with the cloud wow yeah like i can
totally see
again i'm still a little skeptical i'm
blown away that this is possible but i
see the benefit of being able to just
say let me try out all these different
configurations for my workload
and and so i'm curious what are some
other things that you think are pretty
cool about this type of hardware that
might not be obvious to someone like me
who doesn't do this kind of stuff as
deeply as you do right it's good you may
think hey i can get the same hardware
from a hardware store or halloween
vendor but it's actually
not well it's complicated because you
you buy hardware like you you buy a new
machine and you use it for
three four years right you don't need
you don't buy
a new server every month
and we with cloud
you just need to shut down the machine
change the configuration and reboot and
then you get access to the latest
hardware without paying any upfront cost
so if you want to say
use the latest xeon processor or ssd or
nvme or md milan then you just need to
change the configuration and
then you keep all the data all the
configurations and just get the latest
hardware for like free like without any
upfront cost
so i think that's that's pretty cool
like
you can actually
use the latest hardware anytime on cloud
and actually cloud is one of the
first earliest places to support such
like latest generations of hardware
oh man that killed my argument because i
was just gonna be like well why don't i
just buy the newest you know technology
but a lot of times it doesn't roll out
as fast like as it would to the cloud
and you mentioned the networking got a
lot faster yeah um so network is faster
obviously you have the ethernet and
and the switch and top of the rock
switch and and the whole back end and
i think the cool part of cloud is you
don't need to think of think about the
actual fabric so we
we support 100 gigabits per second for
network and
each machine can actually communicate to
another machine with 100 gigabits per
second regardless of their physical
position so um like if you're when
you're actually designing a physical
data center you actually need to think
of those
um top rack bandwidth and how you
distribute workloads so you you get the
full boundaries for each machine but
with cloud we we design a network in in
a way that each machine can actually
achieve the full bisection bandwidth
okay so that's a whole thing like from
an architecture and planning standpoint
you just don't even
have to worry about it think about it
this is so interesting to me one thing
i'm curious about is if you were gonna
do a project like this in the future uh
like if you were gonna try and go for
you know another record or something
like that would you still use cloud
computers or do you think you might
switch over and use something on-prem
something more dedicated
i because i i work for clara i would use
it
obviously
there are
obviously
pros and cons for example if you want to
use a specific hardware set or specific
for example
if you want to test a specific piece of
hardware then you might need to still
get access to that like specialty
equipment but for like i think i would
say 99 of the workload in the world you
can just launch a machine in cloud
and
because you you don't know which machine
to buy before
actually getting the machine like so for
on-premise hardware you you kind of do
the guesswork and and i think this
hardware with this number of cores and
this much memory
sufficiently big enough and not too big
but in in some sometimes use some like
you don't have enough memory or you
don't have enough stretch or you may
need to add some cores
and you never know and with cloud
you can
you can just test everything right and
you can always change the configuration
you can always add new hardware um and
yeah so you don't need to choose and and
invest
at the beginning you you just um change
and then adopt along the way
this is a really interesting angle on
the you know people often say you know
if you're kind of doing a batch workload
then you know maybe that's not the sweet
spot but there's this um
upfront like testing side of it where
you're being more scientific and you're
trying to figure out you know what kind
of computer what kind of arrangements
are the computers and you can do all of
those tests in really short durations
which makes them affordable to do a wide
variety of them
on cloud
thank you that's it i'm i'm in the
middle of this and that's an angle on
this i hadn't been thinking of
so i appreciate that
yeah yo emma thank you so much for
coming in and sharing what you've been
working on and the way you're able to
push the cloud you know cloud compute
instances to the extreme
there's a lot that i didn't think was
possible or didn't know was possible and
i hate to admit this brian
the more we talk the more i start
thinking cloud computing makes a lot of
sense
imagine
we all that's it for this episode emma
thank you and uh if you're watching at
home uh definitely let us know of
anything that was surprising to you we
definitely check out all the comments
and stay tuned for next episode because
uh it's a special one i don't know
what's in store but brian said i can't
miss it oh we do um it's gonna be
awesome um
and yeah so please hang in there check
it out and you know if you're living in
the future already just uh hit next on
the playlist and join us it'll be fun
[Music]
you